A crowd of people, active shooters and the chaos
that ensues. Although still relatively
unlikely, it's not an unthinkable occurrence.
In a drill involving first responders from several metro area jurisdictions, some outfitted with body cams,
Emory's Office of Critical Event Preparedness Response (or CEPAR)
tested reactions to a mass casualty
shooting conducted recently at White Hall. The event was staged in collaboration
with the Atlanta Urban Area Security Initiative (UASI), which is made up of
Clayton, Cobb, DeKalb, Fulton and Gwinnett counties and the City of Atlanta.
The task was to take down the gunman and get victims, played here by Emory community volunteers,
out of harm's way as quickly as possible.
"You've got personnel who are armed, who are actively shooting individuals.
It's a threat obviously to the victims and the in the public in the area, and it's a
threat to the responding officers."
As if ripped from recent headlines,
this scenario not only involved active shooters, but mock improvised explosive
devices on both the Emory and CDC campuses. The aim was to test
communications, equipment, and police and emergency medical teams under extreme pressure.
"This was a multi-venue exercise and part  of this exercise not only
looked at the capabilities of EMS operating in the warm zone
under escort to provide free eyes and
immediate life-saving intervention,
but we also surged a couple of the local hospitals with patients to see how their
surge management plan worked."
One of the major goals of UASI is to make sure that
multi-jurisdictional plans and collaborations exist between local core
first response units and their state and federal partners. During this exercise,
the region's tactical operations con plan, which bring SWAT teams together,
was tested along with the region's
interoperable communications
capabilities for command and control. Drills such as this one are designed to
identify gaps which UASI works to overcome or eliminate.
"It's crucial that I know who you are, that you know who I am, so that when the phone rings at
2 in the morning, it's not the first time we've had a conversation."
But it was the first time area first  responders were able to coordinate a plan of action on
this scale since the recent annexation
of the Clifton corridor
into the City of Atlanta.